let me tell you where we now
every time i hear somebody say world
renown i punch them in the face because
go [ __ ] yourself
i hate world renown oh i'm worried now
have you been to compton
because i'm from compton if you ain't
been from compton compton's in the world
you can't deal with me
go [ __ ] yourself world-renowned ass
[ __ ] man i was about to say i'm
world-renowned and i'm luckily here
guess what leslie i was gonna do it
because sometimes it's something i just
said
how many people say world renowned to me
really and it's so hilarious it's like
you might as it's like saying i know kim
kardashian look go [ __ ] yourself yeah
yeah i remember and i remember this
cause i remember going oh my god that's
really embarrassing leslie i remember
when i got snl and i had to meet with
lauren
and uh i was sitting there you know it
was in the
process now lauren's world-renowned very
much
he owns half of the world
[ __ ] leslie come here yes i want to meet
you
that's where i think that you're so
leslie
yeah
oh man so many imitations i love
imitating him he's so funny but i i
remember um meeting him for the first
time and i'm in the office and i was
[ __ ] [ __ ] bricks i just
i could tell this man was somebody who
[ __ ] just
he's the [ __ ] right and i'm just
sitting in this office in front of him
and i'm like
i'm just okay like i'm old too i'm like
47 so i should be able to say something
mature you know like you know and i
trust me that does not come with aids
it's not it does not it does not and i
remember looking at this man
and saying
i can't even believe i said it i said um
hey if you want to ask somebody about me
um call eddie murphy you know me
and you know i'm funny
and lauren was like
um
i'm sure you're funny i'm sure you're
real funny
i just remember thinking i don't mean
[ __ ] yeah you don't give a [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] yeah but he knows i mean
this thing is you wouldn't have been in
his world if you didn't know you were
funny i mean
i was just in that position of just like
i need to impress him i need to feel
like you know you need to feel like you
need to
be
right there with that man
don't you just be you like i didn't know
if i then i really wish i would have
known that just be me i didn't learn
that until maybe six months into snl
that the way i was gonna win at snl was
to be me yeah you know i was trying to
be everybody else i'm a virgo so virgos
are perfectionists and we're trying to
[ __ ] we're people pleasers too and
it's like when i walked in there i was a
dope-ass comic and i'm like i'm going to
prove to you [ __ ] i'm funny
and didn't have no respect for sketch
comics at all this is what i want to ask
you about this because no
respect for sketch comics
when they when they told me to come and
[ __ ] do it i was like yeah i can do
it cause these sketch [ __ ]
don't know how to do comedy they only
know how to do [ __ ] pretend [ __ ] and
they're not funny uh put them in front
of a [ __ ] mic
and let me tell you something
that [ __ ] table read but
sitting between 80 brian and taran
taran and [ __ ] keenan in front these
[ __ ] was changing a voice every
five seconds and doing doing [ __ ] i was
just like what the [ __ ] is like taryn
singing straight like sam smith at any
second 80 just busting kate busting into
rap it was like
what the [ __ ]
i felt like a dumb [ __ ] i felt
like i had went to college and met a
gang of people that's way more talented
than me so it was just now then it was a
mission of like oh i gotta prove i'm
funny cause these [ __ ] are
funny i gotta prove that i can you know
i got i can give something to this
equation and i didn't i really was not
being myself i was really trying to be
something else and until one day keenan
i was smoking we were keenan
and keenan was like man you be having me
busting the [ __ ] up in this room he was
like why we don't see this [ __ ]
and i was like oh look i mean because
you know i'm kind of ghetto you know i'm
ghetto and [ __ ] you know what
[ __ ] he was like man this is
the [ __ ] they need to see yeah
so that's the person so i started that's
when i started catcalling colin in the
middle of the hallway
like he would be standing there lauren
and i'd be like use a fine ass white
[ __ ]
oh my god i've never seen a white man so
[ __ ] fine
and i would just and they would just
laugh and laugh so i would get on the
elevator with him and i know cause he
was always with lauren so whenever i
would get on the elevator with him i'd
just be like
so if i invited you to my house would
you come here
and he would be like leslie you can't do
that
like lauren's i was like lauren wants me
to get some too like
and laura would just start laughing so
it was just like hey and then i wrote my
first update and the first thing i said
was you delectable caucasian and that
was it that's right colin was like yeah
we got to do something with this we
gotta
and i no but i was really in love with
colin
i was in love with colin for literally
the first whole season i was
so [ __ ] in love with him and he knew
it
he knew it and he took advantage of that
love
he really did he [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm saying this and i hope you're
listening to conan o'brien right now
because i know that you knew that i was
in love with you
and he strung you along he strung you
alone strung me and [ __ ] alone
colin i would text him at two o'clock in
the morning and be like no one's gonna
know
no one's gonna know just come over real
quick just come over and he would be
like
leslie you know i got a girlfriend
so
[ __ ] the [ __ ]
i was like i've seen her she's so skinny
you're not having fun with her you're
not having fun with her kyle you're not
having fun with her and i just i
literally was so in love with him and i
think one time one time i did an update
and it was so
and it never got to air but it was that
i remember lauren looked at kotlin and
goes yo
if lauren says yo things are off the
hook all right yeah [ __ ] she looks
yeah
she [ __ ] keenan was like you really
like that dude i was like
let's not talk about it
the day that i gave up on colin was like
a sad day because i was just like i'm
just he's never gonna [ __ ] like me
the way that i like him and then he did
something
then i started hearing things about him
and i was like oh he's dirty
then i wanted him more
you like a dirty guy huh
i love a dirty [ __ ]
well good news
no wait i gotta
know seem dirty at all